the room in the Vatican Palace now known
as the stanza della signora was
redesigned by Rafael between 1508 and
1511 to serve as the library of pope
julius ii the vaulted ceiling sets forth
the basic program of the pictorial
decorations in the roundels are
personified for intellectual faculties
that organize human knowledge philosophy
theology jurisprudence and poetry
theology declares the knowledge of
things divine each faculty is more fully
elaborated in the fresco on the wall
below under theology is the mural known
as the disputer although nothing is open
to dispute in this painted manifestation
of theological truth
Raphael demonstrated by essentially
pictorial means a basic tenet of
Christian doctrine the
transubstantiation the presence of the
Incarnate deity in the Eucharistic wafer
along the central axis of the
composition the Holy Trinity descends
through its several persons from the
figure of God the Father through that of
the Sun to the Dove of the Holy Spirit
and that divine descent culminates in
the monstrance displaying the host on
the altar sign of the perpetual presence
of the divinity in the church on earth
around the altar are Saints Gregory and
Jerome Ambrose and Augustine the four
doctors of the Latin Church who bear
witness to that truth and who through
their writing and preaching served to
spread the Holy Word through an
exhaustive series of preliminary studies
Raphael arrived at a design of
remarkable clarity and deceptive
simplicity a design that responds
directly to the format of the
semicircular wall itself and builds upon
its basic geometry locating the center
of the arc
Raphael determined the horizon line of
his composition along that diameter and
they have fixed the vanishing point of
his prospective construction the
differentiation between the upper and
lower zones between heaven and earth
became the governing principle of his
design as the mediation between the two
realms were central to his theme
geometry served as an essential means of
distinction the circle the most perfect
geometric form with neither beginning
nor end had long been associated with
God and it is the circle that is
reserved for the divinity in roffels
painting from the golden dome of heaven
in which God the Father appears to the
glory surrounding Christ to the halo of
the Holy Spirit
the divine descends to earth in a series
of radiant circles culminating in the
monstrance on the altar pure gold is
chromatically reserved for the divine
and it too extends down to the altar of
the church through the gilded monstrance
to the interlaced decoration of the anti
pentium that features the name of julius
ii pontifex maximus the altar itself
declares the second geometric theme of
Raphael's composition the rectangle in
contrast to the Eternity of the circle
its four-part structure corresponds to
the cycles of life on earth the four
seasons the four elements the four
temperaments which measure the mortality
of man the combination of these two
geometric forms circle and square as in
Leonardo da Vinci's famous drawing could
be invoked as a sign of man's dual
nature a mortal body with an immortal
soul an earthly creature but
participating in the divine that which
was proved by the incarnation of God as
man this is a central demonstration of
the disputa as Christ displays the
mortal flesh assumed by God around his
central figure flanked by Mary and John
the Baptist is an attendant court of
personages extending from Adam through
the early martyrs of the church they are
seated on a semicircular embankment of
cloud here
Raphael inflicts the perfect golden
circle of heaven on this lower level the
circle is foreshortened
that is it is subject to the distorting
laws of natural vision and the divine
purity of gold has also yielded to the
substance of nature the natural stuff of
cumulus cloud through such geometric and
pictorial means Raphael established
the position of this saintly Court
mediating between heaven and earth
mediation is inherent in the very
structure of Raphael's fresco in the
implications of its spatial conception
the divinity descends not only
vertically along the central axis of the
composition but spatially as well the
figures of the Holy Trinity appear to
advance toward the viewer the
culminating altar seems to coincide with
a picture plane itself and its
foundation seems therefore to advance
beyond that plane divine truth extends
not only laterally within the disputer
but also along an axis perpendicular to
the wall reaching beyond the painting
into our world declaring theological
doctrine making it visually legible
sensibly available Raphael's paintings
seems almost to assume the institutional
function of the church itself
indeed that ecclesiastical resonance is
built into its design as Raphael's
golden half dome of heaven invokes the
gilded mosaics of the early Christian
Church the absolute implications of his
design suggests a precise architectural
space by such elusive means the disputa
creates a resonance that is both
ecclesiological and archaeological
in manifesting theological doctrine the
painting appropriates the authority of
the early church specifically the Church
of st. Peter the first Bishop of Rome
the first in papal lineage the original
Basilica of st. Peter's was begun in the
4th century under Constantine the Roman
Emperor who converted to Christianity as
Raphael was painting in fact that
ancient Basilica was in disrepair and
was being replaced by a new structure
designed by Raphael's kinsman the
architect
Bramante by preserving a pictorial
allusion to the primitive church the
disputa associates the modern Church of
Pope Julius ii with its origins and it
invokes that venerable Authority for its
theme confirming what the Renaissance
acknowledged as Raphael's painted
theology
Oh